dance like no one is watching sing like
no one is listening
love like you've never been hurt and
[ __ ] like a goddamn [ __ ]
some gold-plated chains would make a
nice retirement gift
for a very very good slave
college freshman scott d'amiro larry set
a new world record
by using his head to bust 142 eggs
and he now officially holds a place in
the guinness book of [ __ ] retards
i i think the reason i most look forward
to china ruling the earth
is that all of their last names sound
like slang
for [ __ ]
sometimes i will meet a lady at a bar
got the same disease as i do
and i'll [ __ ] her
he says to me there's one way to wake
her up but it's a little unconventional
you go in there and you have oral sex
with her i said by god
so i go in there i'm in there about five
minutes and i come out
i said doc she's choking
why do dogs always race to the door when
you
uh when the doorbell rings it's almost
never for them
[Music]
like i'm no expert but i think probably
uh
most uh rapists are hypocrites
you have a boy i know you have a boy i
know i ain't a girl yeah
and uh but i know you have a boy yeah
a new report from the cdc states that
only one-third of americans use
condoms while two-thirds of americans
are still pretty cool
there is no problem big enough that a
huge black
[ __ ] cannot fix well i guess the biggest
thing that nobody knows about me
is i'm a deeply closeted gay man
what orange is the new black
but not in my apartment building kevin
is the new black
hey this occurred to me today i d
i d which i had to show it again there's
a strange abbreviation when you think
about it i
is short for i
and then d is short for identification
hey for the ninth consecutive year nick
jet blue air
airlines rank first for satisfaction
among all north american airlines
but you know what ranked least in
satisfaction
911 airlines what a terrible name for an
airline it reminds me of that tragedy
hey how about this the dalai lama said
that killing in the name of religion is
unthinkable hey thanks dalai lama i'm
sure everybody will [ __ ] listen to
you
no one listens to the dolly no no that
just because i come in
i order a polish sausage why would you
jump to the fact
that i'm polish right and the guy says
to me well first of all it's a hardware
store
a new study found that men with beards
are more attractive than men without
beards more
great work from the university of bob
seger
i don't care if a guy's a guy a
girl a guy girl i couldn't care less i
love them all what do you make of that
i'll have sex with any of them
doesn't matter so i say you see that pig
that cow you know
horse that remind you of any of your
relatives
she says yeah my in-laws i said your
dirty dog
in game one of the western conference
finals between the mavericks and the
thunder
magic johnson said that dirk nowitzki
is playing like he has three legs which
is a nice way of saying
he's playing like a black guy
there's a real stream of consciousness
thing happening here yeah it's called
conversation
[Laughter]
who is the better man okay dr
martin luther king stalin
what do you call a gay boxer huh what do
you call a gay box no mcdonald's no